Now let's take a look
at Android security.
Here's an overview of the architecture
of Android which is based on Linux.
Android is implemented in the form
of a software stack architecture
consisting of a Linux kernel,
a runtime environment and
corresponding libraries, an application
framework and a set of applications.
At the lowest level is the Linux Kernel.
It provides a level of abstraction
within device hardware and
the upper layers of
the Android software stack.
Each application running on the Android
device runs its own instance
of the Dalvik virtual machine.
After written in Java,
and compiled to bytecode
of the Java virtual machine, which is
then translated to Dalvik bytecode.
The Dalvik excutable format is very
compact and it is designed for
systems such as smart phones that
are constrained in terms of memory and
processor speed.
By using Dalvik, Android can
achieve performance and efficiency.
The Android core libraries
are Java based libraries for
application development.
For example, for
web browsing, data access and
database queries,
graphics rendering, and so on.
The Android call libraries
do not actually perform
much of the actual work.
And are in fact, essentially Java
wrappers around a set of C and
C++ based libraries.
These C and C++ libraries are included
to fulfill a wide range of functions,
including 2D or 3D graphics rendering,
secure second layer, etc.
The application framework is a set
of services that collectively,
from the environment,
for Android apps to run.
The application framework allows
apps to be constructed using usable,
interchangeable, and
replaceable components.
Furthermore, an app can publish
its capabilities along with any
corresponding data, so that they can
be found and reused by other apps.
At the top of the Android
software stack are the apps.
These include apps that come
with the device such as home,
contacts, and phone and browser.
A lot of third party apps
that the user has downloaded
after he purchases the device.